[Music]
[Applause]
Brief Organ To Yoshino Char System and Life
Phi Persian Sham 6 people
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm very happy that the 2200 characters have been very beautiful and para 20
anderen dasoda Arreview 4 t Wing
never 4 Please
continue to support me until now.  Thank you to all the fans for
many years. Thank you
very much for your support. We are very much looking forward to taking a step forward with the new total
.
Curelon Fine Music Meeting a 4 s 4 a Pation Come on dc
to see m 4 Timber King  In
remaking for 2020 face, the file and the world view and characters of g 7
are drawn more deeply this time. In
this work, which is the first work of the Final Fantasy 7 remake project,
the story of Midgar is raised and detailed.
We are ready to do [applause] cansas ender ender ender. We are ready to do
[applause]
cansas ender ender ender.  ender soan do
do Way With
the video and gameplay I'm about to introduce, you'll just be able to dispel the expectations of the version, and you'll
be able to meet that f 7 that you all know well.
Figure Kan-chan pou dou dou
unused  us eno 00 a The power of game fans
Newcomer cerena Perfector infix Ford Border
Fancy Serve
please Walker 3 opa Bar cun Person Palette Marketing Hut
[Music]
[Applause]
Yes, today is Neil's gameplay  Let me introduce you so os 9 do
not to do in for a
Second Ketsu Sweat
San I want one for the paralever
re gone
voo  doo
scare you do me to a p
jeg border bar condition list works Calling chain
put on march 1st Esperway Stale Chan
[Music]
voodoo Force Already here
Audience, maybe I don't want to see other parts a little more  I
think everyone, how about
ipr in through my [ __ ] already sdar a
noa
re the voodoo 4 s 4 Leeds
surface pro Brave Jack
[applause]
you do
nose muscles g b charger st caster
4 s this peewee name drc soup  Six faces good
ender ender ender ender ender ender
pou dou dou
[Applause]
[Music] Hmm
ah ah
genus atb 2 you do for hp bar 3
alber poppy skse gdm
Moody ks 4
gnbd  4 sen's worst a 1 It's a tie-up with a
chai petty cram school
space It's a number of spaces Open in space
voodoo It's like an easy ice cream with a joy, isn't it?
It's a game that you can enjoy together,
so please look forward
to it. It's a game 3 s d 2 r Fire ul bar.
Ford Robo Come on
me
[Music]
Body is about to be an eventer j
the new sar
[Music]
[Applause]
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
[Music]
car
Luxury course
[Music]
Seg
hone
[Music]
Has sexual functions
[Applause]
[Music]
Friction jersey Cha
head
[Applause]
Shooting illness Wow 10 under 4th place creme
temas No pressure
the view
paru do ki
220 Parle concert  But doodle
masu
fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  FEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFE
FEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFE  FEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFER
FEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFE  FEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFE
FEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFE  FEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFE
Efefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  I
've been waiting for a long time, but
thank you to all the fans who have been supporting me for a long time.
And
I think you saw the play screen for the first time today, but you probably imagined it.  I think it was a little different
voodoo Jujuu Ah Ah It's a
coupe Well, that's
why I thought everyone would definitely want to touch
it. Actually
[Music] I want to try
it ana iphone  Join
you guys It's a game
with replays. It's going to be held from tomorrow. It's e 3. The
Square Enix booth is
exhibiting 7 remake playables, so if you have a chance, please touch it.  Sai
4 f 100 nen Big Abe of Back Square nse booth onore
Ah ah ah
Well then,
there is something I would like you to see at the end, so by all means
yesterday
I released a short trailer at the concert, but
today is long  We have a version available so please take a look are you doing
andere version
it
please and back
[applause]
[music]
dish pressure pet gobzer is under pressure
ni
[music]
You can have a nice weather
[Music]
Yao is missing Tobe drama
and voice pearly, etc. 2 books from the boss 5
[Music]
[Applause]
Shaving
[Music]
28 seats
Place
tomorrow Display board fan
[Applause]
[Music]
Ah ah ah
[Applause]
Please see the meeting [Music] Yes Yes Yes
[Music]
[Applause]